all right I'll be doing some kibbutz
saying we've got Hikaru playing here
Hikaru Nakamura playing a life from
Switzerland on the Swiss flag here and
he's playing black against um some
player from what's this from Russia it's
a five-minute game the car was played
some g6 d6 set up pop sure this was
popular with a Canadian Grandmaster
Duncan Suttles and the 70s very
interesting player of you I happen to
have some time and want to study some
cool games check Duncan Suttles Canadian
Grandmaster he was really strong ran
maths and the 70s and he quit chess in
the early 80s I think they played them
basically without knowing any theory you
just played g3 d3 with wide ng g6 and d6
those would like and he did dine
perfectly okay
okay so we've gotten a pretty
interesting position here white hasn't
managed to Castle because of this Queen
c8 Bishop e6 setup and black Holly tried
to get something going with the F pawn F
for now but white has an item has a
knight on d5 which is quite nice of
course I had this intense 95 maybe
so p6 specialty - yeah and black tries
to embarrass the knight on c3 a bit with
a for coming
why doesn't want to play for himself
yeah he did - to add this half this
night hanging on b3 okay I'd like just
play g5 and he's got a nice space
advantage on the kingside it's not
apparent
what wide should do with the King may be
long castle after all okay rook t1 he
cannot Castle short yeah like just tries
to improve his pieces I still don't
think it's not amazing that in the
middle of a super GM tournament here
Hikaru was playing blitz games on the
ICC but he did this for years and well
maybe it's good to stay to a routine of
you not doing well in the tournament I
mean doing something else just because
of the first couple of rounds didn't go
so well
maybe not a good idea so what happens
here black has a better looking Bishop
but the thing is there's the famous
quote from Romanian Grandmaster mahesuan
said bad bishops protect good pawns so
black has got his paws protected and
maybe has chances to attack even g4
those cannot be protected by White's
bishop so he might be able to do
something with his knight but now it
seems he wants to go for h5 to open up a
line for his rook need to make sure to
actually follow him here so that another
game actually will be a cavity
immediately so I think white has a
pretty solid position
it's difficult to see how black should
make any progress here in fact white
might even try to get a knight to f5 but
he instead tries this before yeah which
is not bad a5 a5 is an idea
yeah why Cisco df/dx on now and why the
white should be really fine here right
at five not like changing light
shouldn't be bad either you've got a
protected passport after all
it's not so UD though to get some
progress I mean like spawns be 5 and B 5
really cover all ng squares for the King
so I think maybe this is just a draw
it's a side of a fortress yeah black oh
try play C 5 yeah he does sort of white
if white just stays here and just doing
nothing and this is room
yeah interesting play black tries all
there is to stir up some trouble maybe
he even is successful yeah but now Kings
see 495 could be dangerous for like even
Chuck okay yeah interesting
check 97 King here yeah what what should
be it should be okay here I think yeah
black will get e4 he would get it for
hmm well maybe it's a draw but not easy
for that you know it is you know this is
weird why do I get the King away from
the action yeah now black is winning I
guess this is too much
the H phone
yeah eh pawn just just let's just
remotes here GNH porn is just too much
white resigns yeah he really managed to
what is this another game well okay
whatever it's it's a new game and
somehow we'll miss the strongest couple
of moves I don't know really weird how
quickly this has happened well okay is
playing black here against Grandmaster
Vladimirovich which means Dimitri and
rakin shot 2700 player and a good blitz
player yeah well he Kara already won
upon so he's um he's trying to win here
of course and this is a three one blitz
actually so three minutes and one second
increment this is interesting and it's
crazy how fast they played this
yeah Black has got the extra porn but
also activity with his King King on f5
and these G and H porn of white some are
slightly weak as we see now the H bone
cannot be saved yeah I think black
should realize really resigned
yeah okay next one now this could be
really cool mature so we for played like
we too may be expected e6 I don't know
so not exactly a theoretical dual here
yeah not sure why is thinking so long
just not have six or something
developing or d5 should be okay
yeah it looks funny yeah it's not the
best opening in the world for white but
you cannot refute it really if you go d3
ng3 and so on it's just similar to some
feed or reverse door pill key worst and
well like em should be okay but it's a
it's nothing special that black can't
expect here yeah so white has set up
quite annoying pin on on this night on
f6 young like what yeah I really prefer
to have a bishop on e7 so it's trying to
reroute this and maybe night wow this is
cool yeah funny fun fun shot yeah but
I'm not sure I get it
okay I'm not yeah
this shouldn't be really a correct
sacrifice but it's fun what will get a
bishop on f5 and maybe
yeah Queen e2 to h5 would be nice but
there's a wish upon a six covering the
square so black I think should just be
material up but funny white has just
spent eight seconds here and you got the
increment also
yeah now black must return this piece
don't think this was was the best the
best possible
yeah black really try to to get activity
here Bishop on b7 is a very really nice
piece and you would like to have a queen
on c6 or something and then queen h1 and
and you're very fine yeah well what
what's actually happening here White's
got a dick Suppan and some possibilities
okay now you can take the exchange but
this is an exchange just not so yeah
it's it's nice to have an exchange but
the bishop won't be seven will be very
strong
why should really try to avoid the
bishop coming on the long diagonal
ninety-five knows maybe in idea 95g 495
f3 maybe
the eye once a play Bishop d7 good move
really good move
the bishop really must must go to p7
yeah this is a very nice long diagonal
they decided to get the exchange back
the problem is said that blackest was so
much done on time white was really
playing everything almost instantly and
now you need to worry about 94 to h6 or
rook g4 yeah Queen f6 no I guess
yeah black really did a good job and
keeping and keeping this position
together and we mustn't forget this is
three one so we got one second increment
you cannot you cannot just win on time
it's the second time move so White's
ideas to play on the b6 pawn which is
the weakness and can be attacked by the
knight but White has problems in
invading his rook getting a good
position for his rook yeah neat little
trick here that couldn't take another
five with fork
king and rook yeah white is trying to
activate his rook and maybe he even
succeeds to create him and now it's I
got the rookin like I don't know black
should still be okay I guess
the bishop plans for fits on time
what what I think there's something
something weird happening here with with
the clocks I don't know this is weird he
had yet like 10 seconds yeah okay so
next game next game yeah and it's
actually the the Troxler attack
well black allows Y to capture on f7
completely insane opening check and I
don't know what's happening here
why just earth yeah what's happening
here if black takes the knight now we
get default coming and I think what
would just drop back to or to f3 I guess
it's not not a given
yeah of course you can also castle like
now take the light still d-4s think and
you've got Bishop g5 check coming up
yeah what we should be trying for
complete complete chaos here he wants to
play a form
yeah black is a piss-up but obviously
it's a very messy position now maybe
Korean age five or something
Queen age five Queen G fourth Queen
towards the king and now rook t1 coming
something like this it's it's some
compensation for sure
yeah now look group T for threatened
roopd for takes any five stuff like this
maybe work T for this is puzzle
okay I want to get this Queen d8 made
idea
yeah Ken because it is possible to open
up the position taking on e5 or
something I'm trying to get at blacks
King take six now yeah i know ii five
just e5 yeah this looks like a very
strong attack yeah and what is really
playing powerful powerful moves
hmm he's so he simply did doesn't take
on you take on f6 I would have taken
long ago I'm not quite sure if it is
good or something yeah black might have
some play here okay
Quidditch 8 and now what's this a draw
yeah this is probably a perpetual yeah
they're playing this so quickly and this
is really amazing I mean this is not
super difficult to see I mean I would I
would see this probably also what I
would need get lots of time at least I
couldn't play all this in a couple of
seconds
yeah there should be a perpetual for
both players really I think maybe why
doesn't doesn't want to JA dad still a
perpetual you can give check all day
long okay now what tries to win with
this age porn maybe he can like is quite
active I'm not sure
yeah what cannot really move the age
porn maybe it's a draw
oh isn't it sweat winning him I'm not
sure
so what win now hard to calculate King D
7 c6 c c5 and then grabbing the pawns I
have a black and also approach that I
cannot calculate this a couple of
seconds let's see what happens c5 is the
only move though otherwise black plays
b5 oops
b5 before and okay okay it's a draw
it's a draw I think should be drawn with
the C pawn the C point is at Rome and
white has got the b-pawn extra this was
not his idea great this is so great he
played a3 and some of the well this is
winning
check that the trick is king a king king
in the corner it's a draw are you taking
resign yeah this was really great what
you did there I think here to get if
white the eggs should be pawn so that
that this is really a really winning
I think it's winning not 100% sure but I
think so really cool the other thing is
this is you only a draw because
here white can go in the corner and
Queen takes a stalemate but he's got to
be pawns oh it's no stalemate really
cool so the next game started really
really really fun
so we've got some sort of hmm Kings
Indian attack kind of setup and like it
just pushes just pushes the the pawns on
the Queen side
yeah maybe you can just take our v5 show
yeah why should just have an extra pawn
yeah I mean okay he has an extra pawn
it's just a matter of counting but it's
not not apparent that blacks should have
any compensation can just play a normal
strengthening moves now okay and even
one this exchange on on b8 that's not so
easy I can get maybe one or two queen
size pawns oh but now this looks
critical what should like do now
nights somewhere like detune or
something attacking the the night on IG
5 something gap yeah blacks pieces are
somewhat somewhat loose here
you can just take a six now and be two
black resign it's just an extra piece
and black resigns
yeah you seems to be in pretty decent
shape so we got another game or maybe
both players need to get some drinks for
us or something
all right you got a new game so I think
it looks like we got those this we had
set up Bishop d7 I know okay agents
poses into a Dutch a Dutch lady Greta
set up which is also even plays in in
serious tournament games yeah I'm black
you know akia F form this is really
trying to overrun white on the on the
kingside and to think black black
already looks nice here got nice please
play
yeah black wants to get the e5 pawn and
get all his pieces towards the king good
reform Knight g4 something like this
he's got very nice some compensation for
the pawn we have like immediately with
Wydra media chance the pawn yet to get
some pieces off and try to control the
position now we'll probably look f1 to
get rid of more pieces yeah black is
comfortable it's got nothing to to worry
about
the threads rook takes G to rock G - Kim
G - Bishop f3
why does okay also I mean it looks very
nice for for black but I don't think you
have got anything concrete yet yeah just
Queen exchange now and you should be
okay like look slightly better but it's
not not so terrible
it's an it is uncomfortable okay one
yoke you can get one one point back but
black has got all this play on the upon
this looks like a good idea getting rid
of more pieces we should before you have
got rookie one and so and now grab a
seven yeah still black looks more and
not more comfortable you've got to pour
nylons well while white is good for
yeah black will get v4 so he hasn't
given up anything he will get to get
this beep on but why this could counter
play against c6 and h7
check yeah this should be a draw already
nice little trick here
check
you know white is some doing a good job
here I think defending this position it
should be just a draw to just take its
age five now and how should like ever
win this game drawn yeah drug retail so
let's see if yes so the sick move is
playing we need to remove obviously
against everything like we need seven no
yeah yeah what looks a bit tied up here
probably long castle and yeah black
should be fine it's nothing too dramatic
though g3 black would play Queen you for
I guess obviously for it's a bit bit
difficult to develop your your Kings ITM
yeah I managed yeah yeah there were
tricks I just thought here here here
must be some tricks Bishop 95 or
something but this will also cool with a
night injury
white a sec the exchange so well I don't
understand anything here to be honest
with no now just a five maybe just a
five what's happening yeah he played it
and should like wouldn't be winning now
he's a look up here and yeah white a
sinner in a somewhat weird pin white
resides yeah this was really with a real
wid weird game sorry
so it's g6 time again maybe Bishop d7
Queen c8 again but not in this position
yeah this night if sticks this was also
specialty of this mentioned Duncan
settles he really played the stuff again
taught class or positions
yeah all the time black would take on
before I'm not sure why he doesn't
doesn't do it or at least consider it
but it's just yeah he plays very quickly
yeah we have now a king's Indians type
of position and like has got this g5g
for attack coming I think black should
be really ok here it's not so apparent
how wide should should get something on
the queenside at the moment and this g5
stuff is coming up with two minutes it's
it's I would hate to defend this as
white regardless of yep the opposing
players actual threat I would hate to
play this but against like I'm right I
don't know black will get you for
anything
yeah while this is really complicated I
still like black with the possibilities
on the King but in some obviously rather
messy black could also consider to take
you for now you've also got Queen III
check possibly
Queeny 384 maybe there's all kinds of
stuff hanging I know you for maybe a
rookie one okay I am not so sure but I
played so quickly I mean it's a admire
ability to dash out all those moves but
I'm not sure that they're really so so
decisive for me it looked really really
good for black woody for maybe coming
and now I don't see him playing e4 in
the near future when I would 96 amp like
I said okay I okay okay means better I
mean
check
yeah can what take a five no don't think
so
okay trust to get rid of those pawns
yeah Black has just strong pawns this
Hall Pass pawns and g3 is maybe a good
move trying to quickly use the king with
King G 2 and so on
yeah he managed to get the F pawn
rolling and you still have CNB pawn
while the D pawn isn't so dangerous at
the moment Gaddis looks looks fine now
for black I think
yeah how to to find the movies look at
four maybe ninety four friends who KJ
checkmate nobody can play rookie 7a but
that's about the only move that saves it
we should be for Rookie 797 hmm mr.
swinging the b-pawn yeah the b-pawn
should decide really but white can what
can use a skin
I'm not sure if this is maybe a draw
with the deep on
this might be winning now he must play
Bishop c8 to keep the pawn bishop c8
king c7 and then the b-pawn runs yeah
well maybe it was a draw but very
difficult to say yeah King c7 and then
you just push the beep on or King e7
whatever get another bleep pawn promotes
just b3 I guess or D 3 b3 something like
this
yeah yeah this is winning now the b-pawn
wins if you would have played b3 maybe
d8 check what would have been something
of a difference
Jack c8 and King move white resigns yeah
good job here by by knockout all right
so well this video is 40 minutes now so
this will be the last game I need to get
it get to do some other things and we've
got some weird Sicilian setup after
after some how did this happen actually
b3 okay
nice but what do ass is not going night
age 3 doesn't really have Foursquare but
here now Quincy five a queen a 5c five
major getting something on F to Quincy
five yeah yeah you've got this you've
gotta strand at night they're on h3
which doesn't have a square
if white manages to yeah sort of slow
down this position to avoid giving black
and huge initiative then you maybe can
pick up this night
this could be strong Knight takes e5
what should I play now Queen III maybe
but then maybe who I don't know yeah I'm
the camera takes this time now this
looks shaky in this position I mean
black has got the Strand at night but it
prevents castling and it's really a bit
of an annoyance factor no de force
threatened maybe Queen G to have Queen G
to to tolling the long diagonal you know
f6 maybe something like f6 but of course
first an idea Queen b6 I don't know
really simple complicated stuff I think
I have one G - yeah black needs to get
something going here something like this
hmm
yeah black baby has got 95 to f3 now I
should white develop yeah
maybe like this
yeah really amazing this sort of Korean
knight on h3 really did a great job here
in disturbing white
yeah I don't understand the position I'm
sorry like black should be okay here
really but it's super complicated the
deep bone is very strong obviously oh no
no an exchange sac and black really
breakthrough now yeah this Bishop ah-6
and pawn d2 is really a cool combination
yeah but white cannot allow c3 now so he
needs to take on c4 I guess yeah
takes on c4 must be played yeah white
white problem is he cannot really do
something with his rooks but we never 93
move rookie - this is no check media
rookie - looked XD - okay didn't he
didn't do this even
yeah like just doesn't take taking the
peace he wants to keep the pressure on
really interesting
yeah now what has put counterplay the
rook sign play I guess pretty good
defense by white probably am black let
something slip there but I don't know
I'm really a it's complicated for me to
really tell for sure yep this this
should be winning now really with the
spin and what getting the e7 pawn black
resign yeah thanks for watching I'll
stop here I need to do something else I
think they keep on playing but I need to
stop at some point hope you enjoyed it
too think pretty fun games
yeah talk to you soon in a new video